hi Moses hi Steve mr. Kaufman we finally
get to meet each other here on skype I'm
wonderful absolutely I've enjoyed your
videos and it's a great it's great to
have a chance to chat with you directly
and maybe ask you some questions or you
can ask me questions but I I should say
I think as I've said and some of the
comments I think you got a great style
which I think you know because it's
relaxed and I think a lot of people get
uptight about language learning and you
have a very relaxed approach and yet
you've obviously you know you apply
yourself with a lot and I having a lot
of hard work and diligence because
otherwise you wouldn't have learned all
those marriages and I should say that
when I hear you in Russian and Chinese
and and Japanese I mean yeah you're not
you know whatever it is see two on the
European framework but you're very
valuable and it's very easy to
understand so I salute you for all that
so great thank you see ya one of the
things I think that you we've talked
about is just a new world of language
learning I mean if I guess you've been
at it for what seven or eight ten years
yes good in boxing yet ten years okay so
yeah how do you think the language
learner who approaches say learning a
new language today in what way is the
world different from for them than it
was let's say for me forty years ago
when I started in the Mandarin or 45
years well now we have a lot of places
where you can get resources even even
for dialects like we talked about
Cantonese Cantonese being a dialect they
will say you can find so many resources
on an internet very easy to find so I
think back in your time you at the
beginning you have to probably put in
more work it was probably more difficult
for you to find resources for for for
those type of languages well but now new
age learners I don't think they will
have much of a problem to find these
these resources well in my case even
learning Mandarin in Hong Kong which is
a man during teaching centre or was even
though it's not a place where people
speak or spoke management I had to scour
the bookstores there's no internet
the bookstore see if I could find a
reader with a good glossary to it and
stuff like that but you said okay people
can find resources for let's say
Cantonese but do people know where to
look I mean how do how do people like
most people that's if you say okay I
want to learn Cantonese the average
person is going to go in the store and
buy a book or they're going to sign up
for a class let's say how do you how do
you get how do you help people you know
take advantage of all these things well
as no a lot a lot of people know we have
these language forums and if you go to a
language forum and make a post like you
know I'm interested learning Cantonese
is there anyone here that knows of any
good resources and a lot of times you
get a lot of replies okay you can go
here you'll find wishes here resources
there and I think that's probably the
best way I mean if you go just walk into
a bookstore go to Borders you can't find
many resources on Cantonese you may be a
finer buy a phrase book or teach
yourself but you won't be a fine variety
I think just going to a forum will
really help out the new learner
yeah but step back I mean how many
people even know that such forums exist
or even know where to find them or I'm
an uncle know what a resource is how
many per foot are seriously yeah the
average girl wants a teacher to teach
them yeah that's true
um I don't know like if a language like
Cantonese even if they wanted to take a
course they will actually have to go
overseas because I don't know I don't
know many places in the US where you can
actually take Cantonese as a course you
know but if they have access to Internet
to you know to the computer they they
should know about these language forms I
think my own view suspicion is that
there's this narrow group of language
Keener's including people like you and
me and bunch of others and some of those
that go to these language forums like
learn any language all the time or
whatever it's called I think that's a
very very small group and yet if I talk
to friends you know people that I meet
everybody yeah I'd like to learn Spanish
yeah I'd like to learn Chinese yeah they
may even have bought a book on it
and they never got very far and they
certainly don't know about the language
forms so honey how do you get the word
out to this mass of people who at some
level would think they would like to
learn a leg
that's a good question
um I guess let me see like when I first
started learning Chinese I didn't know I
didn't know about the forums I have to
be honest but I didn't know about the
forums I didn't know about the chat
rooms that much I was just a normal
person I went to a bookstore got like a
pocket dictionary phrase book and I was
using that and like I said before was
using learning the phrase from there and
using on native speakers but I think as
time went by I started using the
computer and started searching for
native speakers um trying out the chat
rooms um but as far as the forms I
didn't know much about a lot I had
people tell me about they say well you
have you ever heard about this heard
about things and not heard about before
they send me links and I go to these
phones and I noticed that they had a lot
of people learn these different lancelot
then they have a lot of advice they show
you where you can purchase resources
whatnot so I don't know it's kind of
hard if someone doesn't have a computer
they will have to just start off like a
normal person too so get a book so
borders are normal bookstore and get a
phrase book a course and just working
away they can work in cuz I didn't have
a set method at the time I was just like
I said I was learning phrases and just
interacting with the native speakers you
know just having fun I wasn't really
thinking about the process either I've
just you know over time I was learning a
lot then like I said as time went by I
started noticing that um I don't know
it's I guess I would say things started
becoming
easier because I was going Chinese and
then I admission started on Japanese
Korean and things start becoming easier
so yeah by the way just an interrupt our
floors out here what makes you go after
languages like Estonian your job among I
can't remember what other obscure
languages you're learning I don't like
it's I don't know when i beginning at
the very very very beginning when I
first started learning languages I chose
Chinese for a special reason and I
wanted to stand out I didn't want to do
what other people were doing
I felt I felt that um I felt that
Chinese was I knew it was a difficult
language and I felt that once I
accomplish once I'm able to speak that
language I will get like this I don't
know I guess I'll say a high respect for
putting in that hard work but if I were
after Lim five Spanish or French then a
lot of people who are they will
automatically assume that I'm supposed
to be learning that language because I'm
an American so it's like if I if I come
out speaking Spanish or French on a
native level then I won't get any credit
I mean sure people will say oh wow you
sign you you're on a high level lamps
but it won't be the same as me speaking
Chinese so real students ionise as an
American ok so Chinese there's at one
point three billion Chinese figures in
the world how many people think I stone
in or Georgian or hammam so work
Estonian mom go flame dislike what those
of colon quote obscure languages like
they're rare languages so it's like I
found it whenever I learn a rare
language whenever I'm able to speak a
rare language people go crazy you know
like why would you wanna learn language
like that but they dig in soul these are
the native also trace these are native
screws asking why do you want to learn
Estonian why do you want to learn Jordan
what is I don't I don't understand like
why don't you learn something like
Spanish or French so it's a it's a good
feeling you know just to surprise these
native speakers but it's not
oh hi sorry okay no I was gonna say you
sometimes I've seen some criticism
newshour Moses you know he claims to
speak 50 languages he can't speak them
all that well and I mean obviously if
you're doing 50 you're not gonna do
you're not gonna be as good at all 50
only someone else expenses his whole
time studying ancient Chinese poetry or
something I mean yeah you're not Kevin
you can't compare the two but I say
whatever turns it's all wherever we find
value and I think yeah I said I think
Moses likes to discover languages so I'm
sure it's not just a matter of wow in
the natives I personally find that - I
would love to spend the time discovering
some of these languages the cream for
example for some of these languages to
see how they work it's learning about
human creativity it's learning about
human beings so I mean why is that a bad
thing yeah I actually said yeah I should
also say that I don't learn these
language just for wild fat no no not not
just for a while factor it's like this
like you said like this discovering and
learning about the way cuz you know
everyone thinks differently you have
different mentalities over in China over
and tightline over any stuff they think
differently right the culture is
different and I like learning about the
different cultures at the same time
right so it's not all about the wow
factor
yeah but that's certainly one of the
motivations oh that's definitely it's
definitely one of the motivations one so
on that first time you have a
conversation with a native speaker and
makes you want to learn more I remember
back in the day my best friend
we literally used to come over my house
every day early in the morning I would
say seven eight o'clock just to go out
and practice Chinese we will practice
Chinese for will be Chinese Japanese
Korean will be there for the whole day
and it was so addicting let's do it
again tomorrow come over to my house
again we go back out to the mall we go
to a Chinese restaurant Japanese
restaurant and just practice a blue mat
every day and it's so addicting it's
these people that you know you're
actually able to have conversations with
them you go back home so I have to learn
more I have to learn more everyone want
to go back use the lousã no ease do that
every day so I mean it is certainly true
and I like I've been focusing on Russia
recently another neglected my Korean but
I meet a Burien person and then say a
few things in Korean and they encouraged
me
well that motivates me not going you
know I I kind of push back on the
Russian little bit and find some time
for Korean I mean obviously that's
motivating there's no one oh yeah
they're very motivating I told you this
one time
um this is very motivating situation
here I went to a Korean restaurant with
the with a friend of mine and I was
having some basic conversation with the
lady at the cash register and it was so
funny because she was it was her and
there was a waitress
another waitress and when I was having
this conversation with them these cooks
came from the vet and an older woman I
didn't even know where they came from I
didn't see him sitting out in in it in a
diner
they just came from nowhere it was an
older woman is a couple cooks that came
back in the kitchen just to see me speak
Korean and ever speaking back to me it
was crazy you know and there's older
woman she was I don't know it was this
crazy experience and that is very
motivating that makes me want to learn
more local language yeah so so then what
advice would you give people because I
you know it's like I'm gonna do this
we're gonna have a contest at length
we're gonna ask people to write two
articles are one one or both that they
want short articles people who have
studied one or more you know foreign
language what was rewarding about it so
the one question is what did you get out
of learning language and I think we'll
hear from a lot of people who who derive
tremendous personal you know reward from
learning out of the language but then
the second question is to the vast
majority of people who had language at
school and then never continued and
never really learned to any kind level
why did you discontinue what was it that
made you stop learning a language after
that school so you got this
contradiction on the one hand the
obvious reward for those people who
to the point where they can speak
another language and the majority of
people who stop and never get anywhere
so you know there is this contradiction
here what what would you how do we get
the vast majority of people to be
successful and returns what advice like
if people come to you in your program
what do you tell them how do you turn
that around to become successful
language learners well I can't
definitely I wouldn't recommend on the
study at university because you're
limited I think I think anybody can
learn a language independently they may
not have a way they may not have a way
they should just start off they should
just start from somewhere just continue
with that whatever lamps are learning
and just you know not give up on it and
um what does uh I mean yeah they should
just I don't know just uh continue start
on that language and you know if they
want to learn Spanish just just
speculated then they don't know what to
do
I mean it's many be more easy to screw
it I mean one thing that is true is that
learning a language is a fair amount of
work
now you may enjoy are you doing it and
it's obviously better if you do because
you do have to spend a lot of time
that's right some people are just not
prepared to put in the time but I mean
there must be and obviously if yeah I
didn't find motivation whatever I don't
know how do you get people to and one of
the things I think I hear you saying is
people should have the confidence that
they will eventually get there
and their lottery but don't have that
confidence they've never done before so
they can't really visualize themselves
speaking other language and I always say
that once I learnt my first second
language then Hey look at me I can speak
quite fluently in another language from
that point on I knew I could do it for
the third or the fourth or the fifth but
it's that a first leg how do you get
them yeah well just looking at Martin
you know what I did at first like I said
I didn't know when I first started
learning Chinese I didn't know I didn't
know what to do I didn't I didn't know
that okay I'm gonna do this first and do
that I just got out there we've got the
resources described and just learn in a
way that I could learn
you know in which in which which was
learning phrases and just getting out
there using with native speakers and
that right there was just you know using
that with native speakers and they're
praising me it just made it more
motivating so it kind of as I was
getting praise like that I wanted to go
back and learn more so it was that fun I
was learning more over time and just
build up you know and I was able to
speak the language so I think what
people should do it shouldn't just if it
they should just start the language and
not think about it so much just get out
there and just try just just just going
to pace update you know their own pace
and eventually they'll come up they'll
come up with their own way their own way
of learning legs just get out and do it
that's all I can say do you find that
your approach to language learning has
evolved over the last over the 10 years
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah most definitely
and I like I said I just got out there
just I've got the Chinese resources just
got out there and used it with the
native no use use those phrases with
native speakers over time I you know
just my learning habits just changed are
you working on Dennis Erickson any
changes how do you you're taking a new
if you were to go out I don't know
Arabic today I mean how would you do
that differently from the way you
approach Chinese and your spot or maybe
already speak Arabic I don't know yeah
well um I always talk about these
keywords and these these interrogates I
learned these interrogatives first I
learned my first start learning
interrogatives and learn how to
responsibles in the rice because in my
experience a lot of the native speakers
ask you certain questions so I kind of I
guess I can say I prepare for kind of
prepare for these these interrogatives
that's the first step I take
and I just expand off of those like if
you asked me well where did you learn
what did you learn Chinese from I will
respond to you or learn Chinese at home
you know I learn independently then they
ask then it'll ask me well how did you
if you learn at home how did you how to
do it
clumps of detail well I have I used
teach yourself or whatever type of you
so that I'll use I learned all of those
first I make sure I can understand in
interrogative and I make sure I can
respond to them once I'm able to do that
then I'll take it further and I'll start
getting into some intermediate texts to
try to build up my vocabulary you know
of course doing a listening at the same
time in you know but the difficulty you
know I was recently in Russia and I
spent the last four years mostly
listening you know an hour a day or so
what I found was that when I was with a
group of friends like our link members
in Moscow there was kind of us at dinner
I have no trouble holding up by him my
end of the conversation but if I go to
the train station where I can find a
halfway I think I know what kind of ads
are going to get to my question my
corners lady and I say you know we're
gonna buy a ticket for the train to be
burgers and she comes back with river
and she's already a bit annoyed now when
I didn't quite understand I said beg
your pardon she gets even more annoyed
and there's five people behind me in
line and they aren't very you know helps
let's say so I've always found that that
it's difficult to anticipate especially
if you're dealing in those kinds of
situations where there's a certain
amount of pressure because there's five
people behind you in line you've been in
line for five minutes you finally get to
ask your question she says something
that you can't understand you know and
and so then yeah it's not always that
easy you need to have a friendly at
least as a beginner you need to have a
friendly counterpart to talk to yeah
yeah I agree agree with that the score
is the situation's though I think that
um once like for me I know that it bus
when I start on the language let's say
you know German or something I know that
if I when I first saw her I'm not going
to be able to put myself in situations
to buy tickets right because I need to
learn
because I'm learning certain content
first right once I get through those
once I get to that first step which I
only take then I go to a book you know
something like a teacher cell which you
can you know they go through all types
of different situations I'll go through
a book and just learn all that stuff
I've got an armored is that there's no
none of the words that she used are
words that I don't know and haven't
heard many times it's just that a she
speaking very quickly
she's mumbling and I'm under more
pressure now because you know very well
that when you're under I find depending
on sometimes pressure helps you to do
better sometimes pressure in fact
freezes you up yes yeah anyway it was
just a situation I was in on a few
occasions where because my Russian is
quite comfortable it's the radio
interviews I can listen to audiobooks
converse I know more that's what she's
going to say it comes out and I didn't
quite understand it anyway
but no in principle I think that's
probably good advice too to try to
anticipate how the conversation is going
to be structured even practice it in
your own mind and so that you can cover
all those bases yeah yeah what the
antics with the anticipation though like
I said from my experience like these
questions like I can go right now if I
go to a Chinese restaurant a Cantonese
restaurant I in it and I've never spoken
to them before I already know what
they're gonna ask me like when we when
we start the conversation I already know
they when asking because I I learned
certain things first right
so that first conversation that first
encounter could actually laughs about 30
minutes right because of it because I
already know what they want to ask you
but if they start talking about certain
things like I don't know if they start
getting to politics or you know just
talking about random stuff like that
then I may get lost because I haven't
really studied much of that I may be at
a catchable Cavalier but I won't be
engaging in that type of conversation
right but a basic conversation like you
know people asking me well you know why
are you doing this or what do you plan
to do in the future if you if you go
here how do you feel about that that
just that basic stuff there I will be in
to speak right you know but
it's interesting too about language like
everyone has their own goals too and
some people want to be social in the
language I mean in my own case I like to
listen to political discussion the
interesting thing is to that that you
can be quite advanced of the language
and you can either not know or forget or
not understand some of the simplest
things like I always find that building
up a languages is it's kind of like it's
never a very solid base I mean it is a
base but it's kind of a gradual and
somewhat amorphous base and there will
always be things that people want to
catch you out on the language did you
made a simple mistake you don't hold a
word for pencil you know you don't know
me there's all kinds of simple things
that you might have learned and
forgotten so it is very much like
swimming in this whole sea of words and
phrases with some stick and some stick
for a while and then you lose them and
it's so that's why I always say that the
whole process you got to find the whole
process enjoyable and you can kind of
sit and say okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
have a competition with Moses to see who
knows the most words or who does this
better that day that's kind of silly and
and often you do get this situation
where people feel like they're competing
with each other yeah you're not you're
always gonna have your shirts always
going to be hanging out of your pants
because there's all you're gonna see
stuff not like it you know it's Jerry
another bin yeah yeah it's true it's
it's then you got to be prepared for
that that there's dirt on your shirt
your shirttails hanging out your
shoelaces on darlin and that's the way
you're going to be in a foreign language
but as long as you're getting there then
right you're doing a job so yeah I think
that makes see this this this whole
thing um I don't know this competition
thing up I didn't start becoming aware
of it until like I think last year
sometime I started realizing that there
are actually people in the community
they are actually making this a
competition right you know and I think I
don't think this is good I don't think I
think once you make something a
competition is stressful yeah you know
and you won't be if you stressful you're
not gonna be to learn the language
swiftly right no you okay I have to be
better than him I have to try to do this
and let honey that's stressful why would
you
want to do something like that plus it's
a bit like nailing jello to the wall -
it's very difficult to master anything
whether it be further you know the verb
endings in Spanish or the cases in
Russian or German you're always going to
make mistakes and that there's very I
think minimal return I think and trying
to nail these things down they'll you'll
gradually get better but it's very hard
to nail them down and it's easy to point
out mistakes in other people yeah yeah
that's yeah that's so easy so easy it's
like oh I'm perfect
you know you're not supposed to make
that mistake yeah I find it I find it
amazing that people will do that like I
for me I don't unless someone asks me
like if if I have more experience than
you in a language like Arabic right and
you know if I hear you make a mistakes
I'm not going to come on say all you
messed up right there unless you unless
you ask me I joke unless you unless you
ask me to correct you I'm gonna correct
you that's just not in me like oh yeah
although I tell people to crew in my
videos I'll tell the next-biggest
look if I mess up here let me know cuz
this is the point this is why I make
these videos I'm trying to get feedback
or names bigger but for me I won't
correct someone else let's say unless
they ask me I just know I'm just not
that type of person cuz some people get
offended yeah you know when you come up
correct when you come on correct them
they some people will get offended you
say you know they'll why are you
correcting me I didn't ask you to
correct inside I try to be careful when
it comes to correcting people yeah I
mean I am happy to be corrected if I'm
in a lesson but if I believe that I'm
actually having a conversation like
communicating and then I'm assuming that
this person is enjoying communicating
with me and that were communicating and
then that person starts correcting my
Russian or much panic then I say like
are you talking with me oh yeah Munich
ating are you getting so yeah it's very
stuff's very very stressful like
sometimes when the dirección it's a
lesson that's one thing but yeah
so tell me how do you think then that
because right now the vast majority of
people learning languages are in schools
do you think that will change
you think about uh more learners are
learning independent uh yeah I think
well I think what I think once more
people start to realize it that the the
best way to learn is independently they
they will definitely stop taking
languages in school
it's just a lot of people that are
taking language school they don't know
they don't know they don't believe that
they can do it on their own but I had a
student Jason I worked with him for you
know in Japanese and he studied Japanese
at he studied Japanese at OSU for I
think three years three and a half years
so um he sent me a message she wanted to
study I don't know I guess he wants to
get more conversational in Japanese so
he contacted me and we met we met up
that place and we tried I was hoping
that cuz he told me he told me he
studied for three years only okay study
Japanese for three years so this guy
must be conversational he must be a must
at least be able to converse in Japanese
so we met up at UH a restaurant I tried
to engage in a conversation with him and
he could barely have a conversation now
I wasn't disappointed cuz I already knew
I knew I knew that you know there are
some limitations you know when you take
in language at university right so he
was trying to have a conversation with
mean it was it was pretty bad so wants
to be started with each other this was
like after the first week I show him
these different things he needs to do
and he was just amazed because it was a
different approach he said wow he's like
this is very very useful right why don't
they teach us this in school he disses
actually says why don't they teach us
how to learn language like this in
school you know so I mean it wasn't like
a genius things that I knew because you
know what my experience I know what to
do now I talked my language but he
didn't know because you know he was just
in second American University but now
that he knows I think that he's more
leaning towards the independent approach
right I know that he will be taking more
language at the University
what about maybe if I'm a question here
we don't want to be going to none what
if you went back to your own elementary
school and they said to you okay Moses
you can take over to our language
instruction here what would you do let's
go you are getting with younger kids
here what would you do to help the
younger kids to develop an interest in
management uh I don't know
well kids I don't know you I will make
the process definitely make a process
fun it has to be fun right I will find I
will find ways to make the process fun
to get the kiss you know motivated to
learn languages I won't do this
grammatical approach that will be gone
that will be totally eliminated no
grammar I will take that up not I always
say this always say this my videos that
I love Graham I don't have anything
against Marren but as a beginner
learning a language that is the worst
approach unless you're unless unless
you're a linguist and I think a lot of
linguists are the people to study
linguistics linguistics that they will
they like to study grammar at beginning
that's just because they're just want to
learn know the linguistics of the
language well if I'm trying to learn the
language I want to be able to be able to
converse I'm not learning grammar so if
I'm in a school trying to teach someone
else a foreign language I'm taking the
grammar medical for the grammatical
approach how we want to take a more
natural way and the way that I sensed
you before learning certain things first
you know interrogatives all that good
stuff and then move on later on to some
intermediate X advanced text and then
after they're able to start speaking the
language pretty well then you know if
they want to learn grammar then we can
start jumping into grammar well I'm
certainly agree with you there like
Russian has very difficult grammar and
it's only now that certain rules and
certain patterns are becoming obvious to
me and that's not because I didn't try
to read the rules at the beginning idea
they just even if I didn't they didn't
make sense and and and I didn't even
notice what they were talking about in
the language like some of the things are
quite obtuse so yeah I think grammar
it's something you visit from time to
time and the bigger the broader your
base in the language the more you can
actually deal with with grammar I must
say rather be different somewhat I think
this is a matter of personal preference
is that I tend to prefer to kind of be
on my own listening and reading building
up my vocabulary I'm I'm less concerned
about being able to engage people in the
initial period but I know there are a
lot of people the first thing they want
to do speak so if you get in if you give
them some structure some tools some
ability to actually engage people in
conversation this is very motivating for
oh yeah oh yeah that's what and that's
what I will be trying to do I'll be
trying to get the students to you know
start conversation early right you know
but again like I do believe that the
listening and the listening part is very
very important it's very important to
get that listening in there but at the
same time I have to get up there because
it's very much when you speaking to
someone and they can understand you when
you're uttering something if upset some
to you say wow this guy he's actually
speaking to me you get this it's like
wow I want to go back and learn more you
keep doing that you do that for a surf
period of time you you don't you know
you're speaking a language pretty pretty
well so I think just if you can get the
students to start speaking right away
like just engage a simple conversation I
think they will be very very motivated
you want to learn the language is it's
fun it's fun when you're able to do that
okay but you know what closes I I think
we probably stopped the recording here
because one of the difficulties with
Kirk we probably talked for another five
hours since hours watch any of it it
knows not everybody is going to sit and
listen for 4050 minutes old uh I think
this has been great I'm gonna shut down
the recording we can have a bit of a
chat after that but I'll shut this down
and I think we could say thank you for
everyone who listens through this far in
our in our interview okay bye